[Music]
white is doing extremely well right now
everybody
and i mean oh gosh he sucked the piece
because it's
mate you bring a rook up for rook lift
styling
here there it is that's me
oh what a comeback win amazing
amazing if he wants a rookie five oh
fish 56 oh he blundered it and bishop
just had to check
a huge blunder by mama jarov he loses an
exchange
you tip the knight on a6 to distract the
bishop away and now after rook d7
e7 and a7 run attack take here and rook
b7
and vidic winning this game fitted
gujarati is winning thanks to a huge
miscalculation
by mom and jarv when they're rooks in a
row you have to be very careful
and maybe i'm speaking too soon is it
quite winning b3
king e3 you get your king here first and
then put your rook on b7 so i think you
are in time to play king e3
here you go bring the king closer you
also can play f4 check if you need to
and get your rook on over to b7 f4 check
okay bring between d2 first i like
putting the pawn on dark square
and that's why mama jarvis trying for
some kind of bishop one but rook g7 does
the trick
and after rook g7 the h pawn
i didn't like that i'm just gonna say
quincy wait wait there's queens g7 of
bishop f6 is that what he missed
what are you trying to go bishop f6 oh
it's going see if he sees it oh my gosh
if he sees it oh my god he's like what
did i just
f7 check and then you go back and you
have rook g7 back in rook g6
check and then you win everything on f6
you're taking more
than one wait there's rick f6 rook at 60
missed it oh my god
i mean it still was winning for white
but
oh wow just resigned sergey
tied match bro oh my gosh you just
missed me g7
what just happened he just gave up the
f-pawn he went f5 and he just left his
king out to dry
unbelievable wow he has just went from
winning
to now hikaru's in the driver's seat the
king is being flushed out
that was what you call an unnecessary
aggressive move
and unforced error no gosh 93 there's
rook c7 so he doesn't take and now
you're taking
all the pawns here icaru is going to win
this game and win the title
incredible what a turnaround f5 was so
unnecessary
but it's bullet he he's trying to draw
it now he's desperate
his queen is so there's a blunder he
couldn't take out f4 because the rook
was hanging
so that was a big blunder by hikaru
there yeah but look at icarus position
he doesn't have to because look at his
king look at his game he's getting mated
on the spot that's amazing hikaru
nakamura
boy you've got to play perfect chess to
beat him kudos to federer
but once again look at icarus
will he see it queen f1 check
you go this way you lose on g2 if you
take get rook a1
check mated on the back rank my heart is
beating he's got 92
okay f1 will he see it he might play
knight g3
oh my god he's got to repeat moves once
and now oh no
he doesn't see it he doesn't see it okay
but he's still probably winning he's
probably
still winning oh my gosh danya teamwork
makes the dream work if only he had a
partner
that he would be able to find that maybe
it still looks really good knight
are we sure about this knight f1 and
rook a3 maybe but then knight c3
oh 92 going back for the mates king h8
no more checks
okay what's the threat queen h4 is the
mage queen g1 queen one queen h one
queen
quinn h2 on her night legs oh my god
but the back ring for black is weak
you're right oh my goodness the fact
rang through blocking
it knight one takes what shaq
he plays a4 first but you get it right
the point is
jan is in complete control here and with
nordie only having 20 seconds he's going
down
bishop to e4 mrs mate that's why i grab
my head sometimes a niche because people
make blunders and if
y'all just miss appreciate me god
oh my god that i was like
i was freaking out okay everybody
i'm not crazy i'm not crazy it's
checkmate
one that's why i freaked out and john
misses it and plays queen to e6
oh my god
oh my gosh whoa sick
wait is kidding me oh my gosh jeffrey
just came
oh that's a huge huge move i mean white
is still better but that's a lion's
share of his advantage
we need to look at that again and the
move d5
blocked the queen from retreating but
more importantly allowed this insane
tactic of queen h2 check
he's trying to keep the smile off his
face i could tell serrano is trying to
smile
look at him biting the ends of his lips
and he should smile that is a sick idea
okay queen g7 initially now it threatens
queen takes a7 is mate
oh he does it look at that he didn't
shoot him at gavin dude that was nasty
oh my goodness wait no i lost the rook i
was like wakes up a ton of material but
then i realized there's a missing rook
but those pawns are two somebody is
still up about to be up a ton of
material as soon as he plays ac
takes g3 though watch out for that move
bishop g3 so that's why he brought his
queen back because uh that palm is
hanging over there
okay rookie eight okay queen slides over
to eight two no oh
[Music]
wow it's a good move g7 okay
so can you start to also have ideas of
rook d3 and like queen e1 check and then
bishop d5 and some sort of mating then
that actually looks very tempting oh
well okay it didn't work as a queen c1
but it's certainly something
very nice technique here by better
honestly he's in great form right now
ricky wants me
i missed it oh oh my gosh
oh my goodness
oh and did it just shook his head oh my
gosh
i saw the uh the eval bar scream mate in
one i was like where is it i told you
it's not the eval for today it's dan's
blood pressure
that's what it is he's gonna watch the
clock too he's gonna resign if this gets
lost
yes he does he knows 38 seconds left oh
and now on forecast b7 is a threat the
rooks you want great move
okay seven bishop g3 at some point i
don't know when
where are you okay six now this is a
push i would actually consider resigning
this i would consider it as well
25 seconds left bishop g3 played knight
of seven goes back to c4 rook c3
keep challenging he hasn't got to be
aware of the clock he's got to resign it
and he's got to resign it rook takes up
six it's another point if that's on
there's 12 seconds left he doesn't see
the clock the rook be six his sister
drives us a win
and he's got one second he barely gets
up resigned he's got to resign
he's gone he didn't he didn't he
resigned
he gets one more game with two seconds
oh my gosh i've never been so happy to
see somebody resign in my life
in a game that's not my own oh for you
oh queen v6
you can't take the rook there's knight
c3 don't oh oh my god he dropped it oh
my gosh
they have tricked him and look at the
car banging his face
what a trick i'm telling you you don't
know who's the better player
right now federer is playing like a boss
and just stole hikaru's queen
incredibly resigned on the spot and
federosave is ahead of the match